okay ally show me your ring
oh here now tell me what you do for a
living
oh i love my husband
and how did you how did you get that
awesome job
well
i became a better human being
and i became feminine and also shocking
submissive so
that was the secret so what are your
tips to women that want to be a
housewife
to embrace it it's an actual job you
just can't get it in the public or
private sector like you need you need a
man to hire you for it but that's okay
because if you think about it you submit
to your boss who makes you clean stupid
shelves at your retail job right like
wouldn't it be better if you were
cleaning your own shelves at home you
what do you mean and your in your boss
wants to sleep with you in a good way in
a good way
and where where do you meet these men
well i think women should work for the
men that they want to pursue i know that
sounds crazy but it's really easy so if
you think about it like you want a
lawyer right so then you should be a
paralegal or if you want a dentist then
you should be a dental hygienist but
these are considered i guess high value
status professions but i think that's a
really good model that not enough women
utilize because women will bully the
woman who is the secretary that married
the doctor okay but who has the last
laugh like her in her mick mansion with
her husband who's high and the babies
like that's that's who has last laughs